today's video is sponsored by nordpass
create and store your passwords easily
and securely with the cyber security
experts from nordvpn more on them in a
bit
picture this you're 50 000 feet in the
air it controls an experimental tiny
rocket-powered airplane designed for one
purpose to fly as fast as it possibly
can your mission is to do something no
human being has ever done before and you
know that any number of things one small
mistake a tiny flaw in the plane's
design bad luck or the whims of fate
could conspire to lead to your sudden
and very violent death most people would
say you'd be crazy to even consider
doing such a thing but then most people
aren't chuck yeager over a career that
spans seven decades jaeger became one of
america's most famous aviators primarily
known for his feat of being the first
pilot to fly faster than the speed of
sound in 1947 but chuck jaeger was so
much more than that one admittedly
awe-inspiring flight he was also a war
hero but a trailblazing test pilot who
helped to expand our knowledge of the
way aircraft behaved at high speeds and
high altitudes a critical foundation for
mankind's ascent into space he also
transcended the cockpit to become a
cultural icon with books and movies
being made about his deeds we'll tell
you today about chuck yeager's
extraordinary life and hopefully we
won't go too fast for you
charles el rodriguez was born on
february 13 1923 on a farm in rural west
virginia chuck did want to be a farmer
so with few other options available he
joined the army a few months after
graduating from high school in 1941
originally enlisted aircraft mechanic
the outbreak of world war ii provided
the catalyst for his advancement as he
was accepted into flight school and
commissioned as an officer sent to
europe jaeger flew p-51 mustang fighters
and participated in deadly aerial duels
with the german luftwaffe in march 1944
his airplane was shot down over occupied
france and he spent three weeks behind
enemy lines before escaping to neutral
spain with the help of the french
resistance returning to england jaeger
protested against a policy that
prohibited him from flying over enemy
territory since he had already been shot
down once and had been helped by the
resistance after an appeal to supreme
allied commander general dwight d
eisenhower jaeger was given permission
to resume flying jaeger would go on to
see more combat including a memorable
occasion when he became an ace in a day
being credited with downing five
aircraft on a single mission he ended
the war with 11.5 aerial victories on
his tally as well as both the silver and
bronze stars and the distinguished
flying cross he had his pick of
assignments when he returned to the us
but instead of getting himself some
cushy desk job jaeger got himself
involved in work that was arguably more
dangerous than anything he'd seen in the
war
he became a test pilot
the post-war world was one of remarkable
scientific advancement in all fields but
particularly in aviation as the us
military tapped the knowledge of german
scientists captured at the end of the
conflict in europe nazi germany had been
at the forefront of aviation technology
including the first operational
jet-powered fighter and rudimentary
ballistic missiles and the united states
wanted to incorporate that knowledge for
itself especially once it found out that
the soviet union was doing the same
thing to create aircraft that could fly
faster and higher than anything ever
seen before the military needed to test
various designs in the air most of this
testing was conducted at moroccan army
airfield in the mojave desert of
california today called edwards air
force base the pilot stationed at morocc
were an eclectic bunch and with good
reason being a test pilot was
exceedingly dangerous on average each
pilot had a 53 chance of being killed in
the line of duty meaning that each man
brave enough to climb into one of these
experimental planes knew that they were
taking their life into their hands each
time they went up among this group of
pilots was 24 year old chuck yeager he
was considered one of the best which is
why i was selected for one of the most
important test flights in aviation
history up to that point aircraft
designers had been unable to design a
plane that was capable of breaking the
so-called sound barrier firing faster
than the speed of sound approximately
750 miles per hour the stresses placed
on both pilot and plane as they
approached mach 1 were enormous and even
if the airframe survived without tearing
itself apart it was not uncommon for a
pilot going that fast to lose control
and crash which usually meant certain
death in 1947 the united states air
force believed that it had a plane that
could break the sound barrier the bell
x-1 a state-of-the-art rocket-powered
plane that was designed to be dropped
from a modified b-29 bomber at altitude
to save fuel but who would be brave
enough or crazy enough to fly it not top
bell aircraft pilot slick goodlin who
refused to make an attempt on the sound
barrier unless he was paid a king's
ransom of 150 thousand dollars the
equivalent of 1.75 million today the
military turned to jaeger who agreed to
go for it on the 14th of october 1947
chuck yeager strapped into the x1 that
had christened a glamorous glennis after
his wife preparing to fly faster than
any man had ever gone before in a tiny
plane painted bright orange to make it
more visible to observers on the ground
what he hadn't told anyone was that two
days before the flight had fallen while
horseback riding and broken two ribs he
concealed the injury from the air force
so wouldn't be pulled from the mission
the pain was so bad that he needed to
use a broom handle to secure the x1's
hatch since she couldn't reach it by
hand when the b-29 mother ship reached
an altitude of 45 thousand feet jaeger's
plane was dropped from it and he
activated the engine shooting off across
the southern california sky faster and
faster he flew calling out his progress
over the radio mach .97.98.99
and then ground observers heard a loud
bang exploding across the desert
everyone assumed jaeger had crashed and
feared the worst for the young pilot but
what they'd heard was actually a sound
unfamiliar to their ears a sonic boom an
extremely loud shock wave that occurs
when an aircraft reaches a speed faster
than the speed of sound he'd done it by
the time the x1 landed safely chuck
yeager was a national hero the first
recorded supersonic man alright we'll
get back to today's video in just a
second but first here's a quick word
from today's great video sponsor nord
pass nordpass is a next generation
password manager where cyber security
meets modern convenience how many times
have you struggled to remember those
passwords you only use once or twice a
year suddenly trying to reset a password
and you can't remember the name of your
first grade teacher before you know it
half an afternoon is gone nordpass is
the perfect solution to your password
management problems installs all of your
login and credit card information in one
super secure password vault letting you
autofill any login with just a single
click but nordpass isn't just a
one-trick pony its password health
feature analyzes your passwords letting
you know if they're too old too weak or
being used across too many websites if
they are you can use its password
generation tool to create and store new
more secure passwords and if that's not
enough it's also got a data breach
scanner a cool nordpass tool lets you
know if your login or credit card
information has been leaked somewhere
online and of course it's all designed
and managed by the same experts who run
nordvpn so you know they've got that
proven track record of internet security
right now you guys can get 70 off a
two-year nordpass premium plan at
nordpass.com forward slash biographics
or use the code biographics at checkout
plus you get an additional month for
free wonderful now back to today's video
[Music]
again rather than resting on his laurels
he continued to fly dangerous and
important test flights for the air force
in 1953 set a new speed record when his
upgraded x1a aircraft reached a speed of
back 2.44 granted almost immediately
afterwards he lost control of his plane
and dropped over 50 000 feet in less
than a minute but he was able to recover
and land without further incident and as
the aviation saying goes any landing you
walk away from is a good one after a
stint commanding squadrons of fighter
jets in 1962 jager was given a promotion
to colonel and a new assignment the
first commandant of the usaf air force
research pilot school which was given
the responsibility for training
something totally new astronauts jaeger
and the other test pilots worked on high
speed high altitude flights and helped
pave the way for sending men into outer
space and with many people considering
jaeger to be one of the air force's most
outstanding pilots it seemed only
fitting that he'd be put in charge of
training america's best to eventually
send them to space from the outside it
might seem strange that someone as
experienced as jaeger was wasn't
selected himself to become an astronaut
jaeger was the same age as alan shepard
the first american in space and had far
more experience as both a test pilot and
a combat aviator but the key difference
between them was that shepard had
graduated from the united states naval
academy while jaeger had never
progressed past a high school education
and had started off his career as an
enlisted man nasa and the u.s government
only wanted college graduates in the
astronaut core as part of the carefully
cultivated public image that they were
creating around the space program being
made up of america's best and brightest
for his part jaeger never appeared to be
bothered about not being asked to go to
space in his autobiography he
essentially claimed astronauts were more
glorified lab rats the actual pilots
calling them essentially passengers
thrown the right switches on
instructions from the ground still
there's no way to know for sure if jager
would have taken them up on the offer if
it had been extended eventually the
decision was made to make nasa an
entirely civilian run agency and
responsibility for training astronaut
candidates was taken away from the
military branches still 26 men trained
by jaeger went on to become astronauts
including frank borman commander of the
apollo 8 mission that was the first to
orbit the moon and michael collins the
pilot of the apollo 11 mission where
neil armstrong became the first man to
walk on the moon's surface in one
instance however jaeger found himself at
the center of a controversy about who
wasn't selected to be an astronaut
rather than who was according to jaeger
he was forced by air force chief of
staff curtis lemay to increase the size
of his class program so that a black
candidate ed dwight was included lamay
told jaeger that he was receiving
pressure from the kennedy white house on
the subject and jaeger had no choice but
to acquiesce dwight was ultimately not
selected to become an astronaut despite
a massive publicity campaign surrounding
his candidacy which dwight blamed on
racial discrimination in his
autobiography dwight intensity faced
bigotry and prejudice from jaeger and
the other instructors at arps while he
was enrolled there and that they did
everything in their power to force him
to fail out of pure racism jaeger on the
other hand argued that while he and his
instructors felt resentful that dwight
had been shoved down their throats for
political reasons he treated dwight as
barely as he did every other student and
that the reason he struggled was because
he wasn't as good of a pilot as the
other students were the truth as usual
probably lies somewhere in the middle
dwight probably did face racial bigotry
while enrolled at arps an unfortunately
common occurrence considering the racist
attitudes prevalent at the time however
there is virtually no evidence beyond
dwight's own accounts that jaeger
himself was a racist or behaved
discriminately towards black people and
in any case jaeger had no control over
who nasa did or didn't pick to join it
to astronaut corps anyway gion bluford
would eventually become the first
african american to go into space 20
years later in 1983 aboard space shuttle
[Music]
challenger december 1963 jaeger's test
flying career came to an abrupt end when
the nf-104 jetty was piloting went dead
stick losing complete control and
entering a flat spin after losing 95 000
feet of altitude diego decided the
aircraft was unrecoverable and triggered
the ejection seat before he could fully
separate from his ejection seat the
white hot rocket motor struck him in the
face shattering his helmet visor and
scenting his emergency oxygen supply on
fire yeah suffered serious burns to his
face which required a long and painful
recovery process after this near-death
experience jaeger decided to test flying
and setting records was a younger man's
game that didn't mean that he took his
foot off the accelerator however in 1966
he was given command of a fighter
squadron and command admissions over
south vietnam as that conflict was
heating up flying the f-4 phantom
fighter in 1969 he was promoted to
brigadier general and made the vice
commander of the 17th air force
stationed in west germany he would later
go on to serve as a diplomatic advisor
to the pakistani air force putting him
at the center of a potential diplomatic
incident when the passenger plane
assigned to him was destroyed during an
air raid by the indian air force during
the 1971 indo-pakistani war yeager rage
show anyone that would listen that
indira gandhi had ordered his plane
destroyed to give uncle sam the finger
in 1975 after a 33-year career general
jaeger retired from the air force his
fame as a pilot had long ago been
eclipsed by that of the astronauts and
he might have faded into a relative
historical footnote where not for the
publication of a book called the right
stuff in 1979 by author and journalist
tom wolf in the book woolf shows that
the achievements of the mercury seven
the original men picked to be astronauts
by nasa would not have gotten off the
ground were not for the groundwork laid
by test pilots such as chuck yeager the
best-selling book was adapted into a
film in 1983 with sam shepard portraying
jaeger on screen jaeger himself appeared
in a cameo role in the critically
acclaimed film which introduced his name
and deeds to a whole new generation of
americans probably never heard of him
jaeger's newfound popularity found him
thrust back into the public in a variety
of ways his autobiography published in
1985 was a bestseller so were a series
of video games published by electronic
arts that featured jaeger's name and
likeness and that he served as a
technical advisor on he was twice
invited to drive the pace car for the
indianapolis 500 and he appeared in a
series of television advertisements for
auto parts company ac delco on a more
somber note jaeger was appointed by
president reagan to the rogers
commission which investigated the
catastrophic destruction of the space
shuttle challenger in january 1986
during a launch watched by millions of
people on live tv the explosion just 73
seconds into the flight killed all seven
astronauts on board including new
hampshire school teacher christa
mcauliffe mcauliffe was supposed to be
the first ordinary person in space the
focus of a massive publicity campaign
that now had turned to disaster over the
course of four months jaeger and the
rest of the commission including former
astronauts neil armstrong and sally ride
held hearings and collected evidence to
uncover what went wrong the commission
found that a critical part inside one of
the boost rockets failed because of
freezing cold weather at the site on the
day of launch this allowed a jet of
white hot burning gas to leak out of the
side of the rocket punching a hole in
the external fuel tank and igniting the
contents blowing the entire shuttle
apart the commission's report was highly
critical of nasa's leadership for
ignoring warnings from engineers and
prioritizing their launch over safety
[Music]
jaeger's post-retirement years were
largely spent in comfort having amassed
a sizable fortune from book royalties
endorsement contracts and speaking
engagements jaeger lived with his wife
glenis in northern california until she
died of ovarian cancer in 1990 after 45
years of marriage the couple had raised
four children together two of which
followed in their father's footsteps
with long careers in the air force
retirement didn't put a damper on the
old test pilot's thirst for speed
however on the 50th anniversary of
jaeger's historic mach 1 flight in 1997
jaeger once again broke the sound
barrier piloting an f15 fighter jet you
think that's incredible just considered
this wasn't even the last time he'd do
this 15 years later at the eye-popping
age of 89 yeager did it again though on
this flight he consented to make the
flight as a passenger the very fact that
an 89 year old man would subject himself
to the rigors of supersonic flight says
a lot about his character not the
jaeger's golden years were free from
controversy however in 2000 the 77 year
old flying ace met and fell in love with
victoria de angelo an actress 35 years
as junior in 2003 they married in a
private ceremony the match caused a rift
between jaeger and his children who
believed that victoria had only married
their father for his money a lawsuit was
filed and then a counter suit and the
litigation dragged on for years in the
end the court sided with jaeger against
his children and jaeger would tell
reporters that he didn't care what his
children thought about his life choices
he was going to do whatever he wanted to
be happy on december 7 2020 chuck yeager
died in los angeles hospital at the age
of 97. the death of this american hero
touched off a wave of mourning
nationwide his body was flown aboard air
force two the vice president of the
united states plane to charleston west
virginia where he was buried with full
military honours in a ceremony that took
place on january the 15th 2021 jaeger
was so well respected that his funeral
briefly brought both republican and
democratic politicians together to pay
their respects often called america's
greatest pilot chuck yeager represents
the bridge between the rough and tumble
aerial cowboys that typified the fighter
pilots of the two world wars with the
highly educated technology savvy
professionals that pilot today's modern
machines though described by tom wolf as
having the right stuff the combination
of guts and daring needed to do things
like break the sound barrier and take
other risks jaeger himself disputed that
he said that his skill in the cockpit
could be attributed to his exceptional
vision a thorough knowledge of his
airplane and how it operated and more
than a little good luck in any case his
contributions to aviation will long be
remembered not only by historians but by
military officers space enthusiasts or
by anybody who watches the books and
films made about his life and
achievements not bad for a humble farm
boy from west virginia
[Music]
you